hello I'm Charlie I'm with Wolfram
research I'm giving a talk about what's
new in image and signal processing and
we have some more talks about image and
signal processing so basically I think
I'll I'll be mentioning all of the
things that have been added to bowl from
language 11 in total our team has eight
talks including this one so there are
more specific talks I'll try to leave
the content that is being covered in
those other talks to the specific talks
I'll try to mention them in the relevant
slides but then mainly I'm gonna mention
the audio processing capabilities that
have been added recently signal
processing things that are new image
processing a lot is new a lot is coming
and the integration with neural networks
which I know a lot of image processing
applications is now being tried using
the neural networks it's great timing
great capabilities so audio is new the
been meat for a week we had a sound
object since very early in Mathematica
however combined with you know the
combination or waveform the sampled
sound as well as the symbolic sound was
not super efficient and then a lot of
audio transformations and effects and so
forth were not super efficient in that
environment plus the that that framework
did not let us handle a lot of large
audio signals or a large collection of
audio signals the introduction of audio
is trying to separate those two worlds
and folks stays focused on sampled all
your data and then now a WAV file that
used to get imported as a sound object
gets imported into Mathematica as an
audio object we have different views so
that you can see more details or less
details it can be played you can see a
little waveform and so for their support
for different devices that can be chosen
or which one you want to play it from
and so forth functions like all your
plot and I think overall the collection
of 50 or so new functions specific to
the audio has been added to version 11
and then hundreds of functions got
updated to work with them with the audio
object for instance you can compute that
spectrogram
lopezville trying to get rid of the
noise and so forth a lot is coming one
great addition that we have added to
audio is that you can just specify a
file path instead of that and then you
can just pass it to the audio so all you
can be great create can get created from
the matrices that the array or a you
know matrix for multi-channel audio
objects and gets created in memory but
if you give it just a file path as you
see there is a file icon right here it
might be just a bit too small and the
file path specifying where to link to
the input form of this object is just
the file path the byte count of it is
just a couple of hundred bytes some of
the things that are really going to be
covered in some other talks so I didn't
include it from the beginning for a
second of audio 440 bytes only and this
is the key to allowing you know access
to very large files hours of audio can
be stored in the file and you just store
440 bytes or so in the memory and then
it can be played nothing again is gonna
be imported to begin with and it just
gets streamed and you can process it at
it as it's being streamed into
Mathematica so the amount of memory that
you're using at the same time is very
limited very little very efficient well
based on your operation it may or may
not end up being real-time but as far as
memory it's it's very efficient anyways
and then in addition we also have access
to URL types of audio objects so this
this particular implementation is
downloading the audio from the URL
saving it and then still you see the
file path of the audio Dhanu icon at you
know separate icon there to specify this
is not on your local file system but as
well can just be played back stream
you know again nothing in the memory
this is all out of course and then also
you can imagine this is very useful if
you have a larger collection of all your
objects and you want to do some kind of
an analysis on them and you don't have
the memory to import all of that data
into your computer especially on
something like this which doesn't which
is not really a very powerful now what
are the kinds of things that we can do
with all you objects as I said there are
a ton of other talks talking about
details of things that can happen but we
can use the whole world of both from
language to create all your objects and
to process all your objects in this
particular example I'm just creating
some random images and then some time
series and creating a sine wave based on
the that time series that you know which
frequently it's frequency is being
changed with the function that I created
with that time series and this is just a
random generate generated all you object
and then just just as I said before you
can compute different things like
spectrogram or additional built in
functions that we have added you can
compute locally measurements on your
audio signal like the M FCC which is the
mell frequency spectrum used a lot for
analyzing and comparing audio signals
and then what I'm doing here is that I'm
basically computing M FCC for partitions
of the audio object this returns a
twelve coefficient per partition and I'm
basically showing a matrix that every
column of it as one M FCC vector of the
audio objects I can take the same thing
and compare it compare every M FCC of
every partition to all the other
partitions to get some kind of a
repeated pattern what's what's the
similarity over time of the signal to
itself at different times and this
becomes some kind of a signature for the
audio object and as you see we didn't
have to implement all of these because a
lot of these capabilities just came with
the rest of Mathematica we just had to
create some basic audio specific
analysis and and the rest comes for free
free and then there are a lot of other
as I said all your specific functions in
this case
[Music]
the same generated all your object is
being reverb you know we're adding a
reverb effect to it so that it sounds
like you're sitting in a big church you
know bigger space and so forth but there
is one talk this afternoon which it's a
workshop actually talks about details of
audio object if you're you know already
excited you want to learn about details
of what kinds of data types how
efficient and so forth that's the
one-hour talk that gives you the
hands-on experience of working with the
audio object more application oriented
talks are going to be tomorrow morning
all your effects is more gonna be just
fun things you can do and
transformations you can apply to your
audio signals and then we have audio
synthesis and audio analysis right after
each other I think in the same room
actually so just so that I can get to
the end of this talk I should stop there
in the signal domain there was not much
we added but there is a very powerful
dynamic time warping analysis that is
used in in fact all your analysis very
much in gesture analysis and so forth
the variance of it and okay I should
start evaluating some of these needs
internet connectivity the thing that
time warping distance does it tries to
get two sequences and align them over
time so saying that time you know time
one of signal one corresponds to time T
of signal two and so forth and so trying
to find an alignment between two
sequences this particular example tries
to get I think three months of stock
data of HP compared to historic data
over five years of HP to try to find
what's the closest signal over the past
five years to this data and so we get
the time set from August to December of
2013 it seems like that data is going to
be closest to what we see from the first
three months of 2016 and what we're
doing as a very naive simple prediction
we can get the next 30 days after that
period that we find the best match in
the historic data and just added shifted
added to the current data that and
somehow have a very naive a prediction
of what can be that
that makes coming you know what can be
the stock price in the next three and
next 30 days or so as I say there there
are some variants of time-warping data
time time warping correspondence and
distance canonical time warping is a
very practical useful version of it what
it does is that the benefits of it or
over the regular dynamic time warping
that is new and the recent version is
that first of all it can compare
datasets that are completely different
in dimension and space so in this case I
have two datasets 1 and 3 D 1 and 2 D
and I can still go ahead and run
canonical time warping and this is the
distance that you get with canonical
time warping of the data that I had
first which is basically just a
projection of the XY with some random
movement and then you see the distance
that it returns is 1.1 and then with
some completely different data you get a
larger distance so as I say you can get
data that are not necessarily coming
from the same space same input and then
compare them using this canonical time
warping the thing it does it actually
does a transformation to the input data
so that they come to the same space so
that they are comparable it's using
canonical correlation analysis and so
forth details if you want to read about
it we have some details in the
documentation and a lot of course on the
web and it is actually used a lot in
computer vision for gesture and gesture
analysis and so forth one of the
properties that canonical time warping
has is that its translation invariant
its scale invariant and rotation
invariant and as an example I'm getting
polygon data from some countries and
compute the distances between the shapes
of those polygons of those countries and
then get kind of a matrix block
visualization of similarity between
those those country shapes and what this
does it doesn't care if one country is
significantly larger than the other one
or if the shapes are slightly rotated it
basically sees how similar they are
removing all of those scale as I said
translation and rotation properties of
them they
there has been extensions to time series
analysis there is actually another talk
tomorrow that goes over the advancements
of time start and time series processing
but things that can be done just as an
instance I get an audio signal I compute
the RMS amplitude which is basically a
measure of the loudness over over a very
small or a fairly small partition size I
get 95 samples out of it and I compute
something else some other property
doesn't really matter what it is I'm
doing spectral flatness here on a larger
partition size and get only 10 samples
back and I want to want to do an
analysis on this audio object the object
that requires combining these two time
series and as Steve I'm actually showed
it last night as well I can just do
something like t1 over 10 plus 2 times
t2 if that's a measure I want to compare
and my father doesn't care if you have
different time stamps and different
steps between the data samples and the
time series it's all very just
immigrated a tree samples appropriately
so that you can compare time series that
that are not structurally exactly the
same okay
what's new in the image domain alright
last year I talked about us starting to
look into different verticals
we have already had some capabilities
for computer and computational
photography Morris come since last year
to Mathematica we are starting to look
at more practical applications of video
processing I should say we are still at
the beginning of it it's just a start
but especially with all the other
capabilities including the neural
networks I think a lot is going to be
possible in Mathematica just like
looking at large audio object we have
started looking at large image data and
so again I would say we are at the
beginning there are some framework
bottlenecks that we have to fix in order
to really have zippy efficient large
image support in Mathematica but we are
trying to work I work our way towards
those problems and solve them to get to
give access to large image analysis and
processing to all of our users and
integration with computed computational
geometry which is not a very far or far
field from image analysis simply gives
us capability of getting an image moving
it to the geometry domain getting a mesh
out of it do some processing in the mesh
domain and if necessary bring it back to
the image domain if not just finish the
analysis over there so these kinds of
bridges between different domains of
capabilities in Mathematica is becoming
more and more needed from our user base
and we are basically trying to address
more of that let's start very simple one
of the things that was lacking in the
previous version of highlight image was
actually the use of extended syntax that
we have for a graphics representation in
Mathematica what we have done recently
is that we basically allow all of the
graphics primitive in the syntax of
highlight image so you have an image you
want to highlight the detected face you
can just use the graphics directives and
language to specify what you want to do
with it specify the face form you know
add more features like I have the purple
face with the green border around it
some yellow edges and some red corners
you know all of it is just becoming more
natural more easy to happen and then
this one is actually using a three
argument form of highlight image where
we specify what we want to happen to the
background of the image or you can just
put anything you want to highlight the
detected object so this is basically
gonna come in many places so I showed it
first but going back to the
computational photography we have added
some specific capabilities like color
balancing this one is very useful to
remove or add color cast in this case
we're showing a few examples of
underwater photography and in most cases
we're basically not specifying what kind
of a color we want to remove what's the
cast that is in the image that we would
like to remove that algorithm itself is
trying to detect what is the imbalance
in the image and trying to remove that
so a couple of examples that we are
trying to take the image detected
cast remove it another thing in that
domain that we added or no people
basically this is the same thing we want
to map the same function color balance
but we want to matter white to a given
temperature which kind of simulates the
time of the day going from early in the
morning to later in the day color tone
mapping is another field that a lot of
people especially doing HDR photography
would be interested in I'm here showing
a very basic you know or not basic but
automatic choice of mathematical for
doing tone mapping the concept of HDR is
that basically you would like to acquire
more data and then most of the time your
data ends up being out of range not
displayable on a screen like a monitor
or a projector so the purpose is that
you would try to nonlinearly move the
data in the bins that you have basically
0 to 255 that you have to display the
RGB image and then get more of the image
that was not visible in the original
captured HDR on a display that is not
high high dynamic range a lot of other
capabilities again geared towards
photography this example shows the
problem of whether I should use flash or
not when I'm doing the photography
because if you do use flash you often
change the color of the object you're
looking at if you don't use it you get
the noise this is the no flash one with
the noise this is the the one with the
flash looking pink and there are
capabilities like this guided filter
that takes the structure of the non
noisy image and then moves the color of
the noisy image to it so that you kind
of get closer to the actual
representation of your image for those
stacking is another thing I think be
sure the version of it last night last
year here I'm opening a bunch of images
that were acquired and different using
different focuses of the object and
performing some focus stacking again our
default choice of method and parameters
and so forth but as you see in the
animation there is there are different
parts and focus of the image and then
you would really like to get all of
those
and focus nests in place in fact this
doesn't have only applications and
photography it has a lot of applications
and microscopy we have a demo downstairs
showing some examples with the actual
microscope sitting there that uses this
metadata support was something we were
talking about as well last year this is
released in Mathematica 11 and fairly
complete if you see anything that
doesn't work it's probably a book just
let us know but in this example we have
a bunch of images from a trip and what
what we would like to do is to basically
just simply analyze it we have a better
support for importing exif XMP mipt see
and now we have a capability to modify
them and export them to the file so what
you see here is not quite correct this
happened there
sorry
okay let's give it another try that geo
positions should not have these select
stuff in them
[Music]
okay don't know what's going on let's
let's move on I don't I don't think I
have enough time to to go over all of
these but despite the select and okay so
we're getting rid of the altitude anyway
so we didn't need the altitude but what
we are doing is that we are computing
against something from the Jui
capabilities and trying to compute the
travel distance that the you that the
person has acquired these set of images
have have potentially walked to get all
of these images sorting based on time so
we use that time to sort the images
using the Geo position to compute or
estimate the travel time and again there
is more of it and a talk later today
called image collections where we are
actually putting some focus into
metadata analysis in combination with
the rest of Mathematica this is just a
Geo plot of the positions and this
probably should not just been here
let's see large images again I think we
showed a version of dynamic image last
year the purpose of this new function is
to have access to images that are fairly
large this one is not still I think fits
into my memory if it does in fact I know
into the memory image size 9000 by 4000
roughly but often people have gigapixel
sized images that really don't fit into
the memory and you need some kind of a
handle to it to visualize and display
the data and well eventually process it
which is not yet available but this
little GUI gives us a very easy way of
navigating the image and see the details
that is happening in the image and I
think max actually I may be able to show
exactly okay so what we are building on
top of dynamic image which again should
be probably happening easier than even
that many lines of code is active
measurements of of anything that you
have in your image for instance in this
particular case I can try to zoom in to
a given part of this microscopy image
move around focus on the object
of interest move to the center adjust
the parameter to somehow get an estimate
of the size of the particular object
that you're interested in so these kinds
of things come a lot again both in
photography microscopy and so forth and
the new function dynamic image not only
allows us to view large images but also
lets us do these kinds of interactive
analysis and so forth and then more next
we have this demo that shows
side-by-side comparison of images this
is also set of two large images a radar
and regular photography satellite
imaging of Venice and then you see that
if I can really if I want to zoom into
some part of the image it's not that
difficult given that your screen is
limited to how many pixels you have on
it you typically don't have as many
pixels as you want to have to see all
the details here we are putting two
dynamic image images side-by-side and
changing control and one of them is
basically affecting both of them by by
using all of the dynamic capabilities
and you can see that we can zoom into
the part of the interest and see streets
and valleys and roads and rivers
whatever is interesting I think I have
to go just a bit faster optical flow
analysis has got added to version 11 as
well here I have a set of images that
are showing some windmills rotating what
we have done in Mathematica 11 is just
this one function image displacement
which tries to find displacement of
pixel values sorry for the poor
resolution image I should have used a
bigger one that tries to show where
every X Y pixel in image 1 is moving in
image 2 so finding correspondences
between all pixels in one image and then
the one after it and then again the
thing I am repeating myself the beauty
of all of this that we're doing is the
rest of Mathematica that gives us a lot
of nice capabilities for instance you
can get that displacement data for all
of the of all of the images in that
sequence and compute the karol on that
which gives you a good estimation of
rotation and then you know this test is
just getting the mean of all of the
rotations or curls over the sequence of
images do some blurring to get rid of
the noise and then highlight where you
had most of the rotation happening in
the image this is this is gonna be
probably a quick little demo if it works
we're using some dynamic capabilities
carry an image and exactly the same
technology I showed above and since I'm
running out of time I would like to move
the time a bit back to save myself
another 10 minutes or so good I have
more time now ok right a lot of actually
again gesture analysis motion analysis
activity analysis is happening using
these kinds of technology in actual real
world so and then again a lot of it is
becoming more and more easy to do I'm
talking about bridges we have this image
to geometry conversion here I'm getting
an image of the Great Salt Lake
binary seing it based on some little
marker that I specified in that little
image and to get the contour or the
shape of the lake and then we have this
new function image mesh that I can run
and convert it to an actual mesh I can
triangulate it with any you know mesh
size that or the cell size that I would
like to have and then we can I think
Steven showed France and talked about
you know looking at it as a you know top
of a drum and seeing what are the
oscillations this is practically the
same thing but since this is a lake you
can think of actual waves of the water
moving back and forth on the lake so if
you want to do simulations like that
this is an instance of where you would
like to take the imagery the satellite
imagery convert it to the mesh domain do
your processing there and then you know
basically take it from there more of
these kinds of bridges are going to be
coming I think I'll skip this one it's a
it's a bit more well maybe I'll just
quickly run it don't talk about it much
we have three images of a of an object
that we required
what we are trying to do is that we're
trying to do some kind of a multi-view
reconstruction to get a 3d version of
the little statue that we have acquired
using the same image displacement we are
basically computing an estimated depth
map and then using image mesh which is
here we are trying to find a structure
of the object and then we are basically
combining them to get a 3d
representation of the Statue limited to
what you acquired with the three images
with more images you get more accurate
and that's one I think is just a 2d
version and this is with the texture of
one of the three images acquired a bit
more intensive for my laptop to run but
you basically get the same 3d graphics
that I had above with the texture on top
of it maybe should have not done it but
I have 10 more minutes right it's just
it's just 11:20 now okay I can think
what I had in slide number 14 15 and 16
neural network stuff nice stuff again
there are a lot of nice other talks we
are how can I kill this okay
came back all right so what's rotating
it now that we have it okay yeah deep
neural network I actually didn't add a
more elaborate example than what Steven
showed last night this this is the
classic M nest stores a whole bunch of
handwritten digits and people have tried
to recognize the handwritten digit for
so many decades now with different
algorithms and now deep neural network
is is actually lifting the bar to a
better better threshold and better
precision so what I keep telling people
as I talk about image processing with
conjunction of deep neural network is
that this with Mathematica is not rocket
science anymore you know some people
come to it
think like maybe it's difficult maybe I
don't want to still touch it but really
are that all it is is that you're you
you just have a network just just a
chain or a graph of operations that are
as simple as dot products and
convolutions nothing complicated or
beyond you know our thinking at least
most of us also have math background and
once you have all of those operations
figured out which there are a lot of
models for what kind of neural networks
are going to work for what kinds of
problems
there are actually a lot of curated data
on what networks to use in Mathematica
you just get the training set call net
train it just does the job and just like
last night I'll stop it at some point
and run it on on the sample data well
therefore is detected as 9:00 but I
guess with that Sebastian who developed
and your network framework is talking
about details of the neural network on
Friday morning and then later in the day
materials from the image processing team
is going to be showing some applications
for image analysis identification and
processing using the neural network so
if that's something that interests you
okay I'm almost done what's next a lot
more audio image signal one cool thing I
wanted to show that I can show in this
version of Mathematica that I'm running
that I should have shown with audio in
fact I showed in slide two that you can
just get an audio object do things like
two plus audio divided by ten and so
forth very Nate you know very very
simply it's once you do it
you know when you do it once it seems
like you should have been able to do it
forever but this is something actually
we can't do for images and the version
that is released but that's something
that should be able you know this is if
I actually quickly get my X here and my
my nightly bill I should be able to run
that but as I said a lot more microscopy
is coming astronomy we're looking at
Fitz and trying to get a lot more
applications this is actually need let
me quickly run it sorry for the next
presenter there is a demo that is
happening downstairs for microscopy I
really want to encourage you guys to go
there so okay so this is what I do I
just compute some hyperbolic
and cosine and gradient and combine them
you get an effect this may look cute in
this presentation but often you want to
do a lot of actual analysis like get the
gradient combine it with a portion of
the image and so forth to really find
some centers of the nuclei of the ball
all kinds of cells that you're there
your whole research is on so you know
these kind of things are just becoming a
lot more immediate and mathematical to
program and a lot more efficient because
you just work on the white data or
whatever kind of you know packed data
that you have stored an image object no
need to expand it to actually you know
64-bit real data and blow out the memory
and efficiency gets worse and so forth
so I guess that's about it
we are just released new you know
mathematical 11 so there are a lot of
new examples on marketing pages some of
these that are showed are from there so
anything you want to explore on the
website and you can find me or others
from the team during the next three days
thank you
[Applause]